the latest on the brutal weekend cold
snap that swept over much of the country
killing at least 55 people the worst of
it is in Western New York State more
snow blew through the Buffalo area
overnight and President Biden has
declared a Federal Emergency there
thousands of Americans are still without
power Nationwide battling the bitter
cold and travel problems continue in
many areas we'll have more on that in a
moment but right now Dave Graber of our
buffalo affiliate wivb is tracking the
record-breaking misery in that City Dave
good morning
Vlad good morning there are multiple
cars and even some larger trucks like
the one behind me that are still stuck
on this Main Road leading in to Buffalo
where they have been since Friday now it
is conditioned just like these that are
making rescue efforts for First
Responders is that much harder in an
already dangerous environment
blistering cold
hurricane force winds
and close to 50 inches of blinding snow
officials are calling the Christmas
blizzard the worst winter storm to blow
through Buffalo this blizzard is the one
for the ages certainly it is the
Blizzard of the century at least 28
people have died in Western New York and
the death toll is only expected to rise
New York Governor Kathy hokel says she's
spoken to many First Responders as the
search rescue and Recovery continues
going into homes going into vehicles and
too many tragic times of finding people
who did not survive the experience the
storm is forcing driving bans to
continue in Buffalo and surrounding
communities with the Lesser travel
advisories everywhere else many on
Buffalo's East Side are still stuck in
their homes while Vehicles still litter
side streets and highways there's cars
everywhere pointing the wrong direction
on roads there's abandoned buses
on roads so it's it's a very very
tenuous situation thousands of residents
around Buffalo without power in a state
of emergency remains in effect anyone
who declares Victory and says it's over
it is way too really to say
it's a storm that's affecting lives all
across the country even bringing cold
weather deep into the South
like in Jackson Mississippi where
residents are under a boil water notice
after water line breaks from freezing
temperatures we can't cook there's we're
getting ready to order doordash because
there's we can't cook we can't wash our
dishes and in North Carolina we're 200
000 people lost power many of them still
in the dark
almost
now there are have been major issues
over the past couple of days really
since Christmas Eve night of looting in
the City of Buffalo dozens of stores
have been broken into
these folks are now very happy after
being stuck in this same spot for the
past four days now back on that note
that notion of looting because we have
seen plenty of instances of that while
there are some people here who are
desperate to be sure people are dead 28
people as of this morning
but local officials tell me there are
many more people in fact the vast
majority of people who are using this
crisis
as an opportunity to steal reporting in
the City of Buffalo I'm Dave Graber
Adriana back to you
just horrible Dave Graber thank you